das haben wir übrigens herr lauterbach
und co alles vorher gesagt wenn ihr die
kinder aus der schule nehmen dann werden
die zahlen steigen sagt keine passiert
und jetzt geht es nur noch um diese
zahlen wieder zu relativieren aber wenn
es um die zahl von der lauterbacher gibt
dies werde in gold gemeißelt ich
verstehe nicht mehr drehen wir schon
wieder über mögliche maßnahmen sind also
ein thema es gewährt bekommen da nicht
mehr raus aber wir wir schaffen uns
stück für stück wird ja immer so ein
bisschen polemisch ist stück für stück
ab und das sind alles selbst gemacht der
polemik ich warte immer auf jemanden der
politik der irgendwann mal auch eine
gewisse orientierung übernimmt und
vielleicht ist der wunsch glaube ich
weiß nicht aber es ist einfach so es
wird nicht besser und wenn ich jetzt
auch holland gucke thema kommt ja man
kann nicht länger nach kann ich euch
sagen dass ich bestimmte dinge lese und
ich möchte das nicht erleben was in
holland gerade passiert
[Musik]